hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr vielleicht wisst haben einige
challenge beim musical ihn bei der
challenge stets quasi darum dass man
eine kettenreaktion aufbauen soll bei
mir war das beispielsweise so ich hab
den ball genommen habt ihr eine treppe
runter geworfen
erst danach in den korb gefallen war
unter dem hashtag wurden halt auch
selbst wieder andere videos gepostet
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir gucken
uns die leute einfach mal zusammen an
erst mal da das hat nichts zu der
kettenreaktion zu tun was bist du denn
fürn mensch unter dem heck der
kettenreaktion sollten videos gepostet
werden wie man eine kettenreaktion aus
ist das beispielsweise bücher
hintereinander herfahren lassen oder so
wie ich einmal die treppe runter und
dann irgendwie einen korb weil gewisse
personen die das hier aufgenommen hat
das ist keine kettenreaktion du singst
ganz normal ein lied ist ein ganz
normales musical ich versteh's nicht ich
hasse solche leute wir sind ein benutzt
du den hashtag wenn es nicht mehr was
damit zu tun hat sorry aber ich sehe so
viele leute bei mir sie kennen dich
einfach irgendwie ein hashtag benutzen
und damit irgendwie gelistet werden ist
übrigens sorry falls sie kämen hier ab
und so ein bisschen wackelig fasst sie
gerade nicht an aber ich habe einfach
mein stativ in köln vergessen war habe
ich hier so bücher tod würden
das heißt ich weiß nicht ob man das
musical wirklich als kettenreaktion
abstempeln konnte weil die quasi einfach
nur irgendwie eine choreo aufgefüllt
haben aber in einer gewissen form ist
natürlich auch eine choreo die
kettenreaktion weil alle nacheinander
irgendwie diesen schulter beruf gemacht
haben oder dass mit dem klatschen fand
ich sehr sehr cool
probst an euch ok ich das bist definitiv
nicht du gewesen ich glaube dass diese
person die dieses musical i aufgenommen
hat einfach irgendwie einen ausschnitt
von domino day genommen hat und den
einfach eingefügt hat nochmal zur
erklärung
bei dem hashtag beziehungsweise bei
musici die allgemein sollte die video
schon selbst aufnehmen
nur falls ihr es nicht wisst ihr könnt
bei der immer noch videos aufnehmen
unter dem hashtag kettenreaktionen diese
posten und das dann sehr cool übrigens
laser so heiß ich beim musical ich habe
heute sogar auch drei neue hochgeladen
wir fragen sich auch ob diese ganzen
musical videos von irgendwie sponsert
sind bei musical hinein ist nicht auch
die challenger mich kein geld für
bekommen es macht mir halt einfach nur
spaß und ich glaube das sieht man auch
wenn man sich meine musiker anguckt
die gar nicht viele spieler hast du denn
alter
dieses musical passt perfekt zu dem
hashtag hätten rechts und ich glaube das
ist bisher wirklich das erste wo man
wirklich sagen denn da okay das ist
wirklich eine kettenreaktion nicht
irgendwie in falsche hände stark
benutzte daten geklaut das video darf
hast du sehr gut gemacht ist official
marco finde ich sehr cool ist passendes
video und wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten video was brauche ich schon
wieder okay dafür ein vielleicht nicht
so eine krasse lange kettenreaktion wie
die die wir davor gesehen haben von
ritter fische marco aber ich brauche gar
nicht sagen wie man meine kettenreaktion
mit seinen daraus dass ich einen ball
des raptor geworfen haben fand ich aber
auch sehr cool vor allem weil er diese
wasserflasche auf gedreht hat und dann
war sie die ganzen sachen gegen die
wasserflasche gefallen sind die
wasserflasche quasi wasser in diesen
beutel oder was auch immer da unten war
ein geschlossenes trägt nach ablaufen
der angriff posten was warum postest du
dass da dieses musical i hat sie mal
wieder überhaupt nichts mit dem hashtag
zu tun warum packst du den hedge der
kettenreaktion unter einem duett mit
kristin hentsch und ich verstehe das
einfach nicht also klar natürlich wenn
man irgendwie so viele leute wie möglich
erreichen will klappt man alle hashtags
die gerade am trennten sind natürlich
irgendwie in seiner beschreibung von
musical ihr ein allerdings ist das
einfach irreführend meiner meinung nach
und bei youtube kann man jemanden wegen
beispielsweise ihre führenden text
einfach und kann man den streik geben
ich weiß jetzt beim musical geht aber
hey warum benutzt er herrscht wenn das
nichts mit eurem musicals zu tun aber
ich verstehe das nicht versteht mich
nicht falsch ich habe nichts gegen die
person die das gerade gemacht hat dieses
duett aufgenommen hat oder auch die
person am anfang ich kenne ja nicht mal
die leute
aber ich verstehe es einfach nicht ich
wollte mal ein paar schöne
kettenreaktionen video darüber anderen
ins tor
mann du hast da als erstes buch ein sehr
sehr schönes buch gewählt nämlich das
komplette buch rico kann ich auch waren
ices musicali hast halt total eine
kettenreaktion gemacht also die bestand
hat nur vier büchern aber kennen
reaktion des kettenreaktion fand ich
sehr cool
wer bist du der literpreis erstellen
war es für weißer stern von al ko nahe
was das was in so fische marktplatz oder
alter dass gerade so ein schöner
sonnenuntergang
aber ihr müsst mich sehen stimmt hatten
jetzt hat nicht so eine kettenreaktion
zu tun man ey ich wollte mir einfach dir
so leicht gegen welche wikileaks
anschauen da kommt nur am gerade geburt
gewünscht kannst du auch was anderes als
denn er lebt einfach wirklich die ganze
zeit ist wenn man so will eine
kettenreaktion von die ganze bahn und
dann die da bauen und dann wieder bahnen
also wenn man es mit nein es ist keine
kettenreaktion
das war's das ist alles hier beiden hat
ein kurzes video aufgenommen wo ihr zur
seite kommt wieder in die kamera wieder
zur seite und dann habt ihr das die
ganze zeit so abgespielt mit einer torte
früher euch für eure voller habedank wo
ist das eine kettenreaktion und bewusst
dass ein gutes musical i ticker was geht
ab bei euch ich glaube wenn jemand mein
video hier sieht und noch nichts von der
plattform musikhandy weiß der denke
jetzt wahrscheinlich nur dass dadurch so
komische videos sind ich meinen falsche
hashtags werden benutzt sachen match
gepostet überhaupt nichts damit zu tun
haben gegen welche musik sie nur heraus
besteht in die kamera zu gucken oder um
die ganze zeit irgendwie zu retten
der hashtag meiner das heißt der
kettenreaktion das heißt man macht etwas
und das ist etwas anderes aus und so
weiter und so fort man kann das ganze
allerdings auch anders verstehen und
zwar eine reaktion auf ketten und so hat
es nämlich auch max verstanden
ich würde sagen der preis für den
flachsten willst des jahres gilt auf
jeden fall an sich bringen herzlichen
glückwunsch von mir notwendig macht
kommen wir nun zu dem musical i was in
dieser challenge einfach wirklich so
meiner meinung nach am besten gepasst
hat es ist einfach von der kuhlen person
gemacht worden die ich auch schon des
längeren verfolge und die lädt halt
einfach auch sonst einfach echt coole
musicals hoch denn ich sollte man auf
jeden fall mal folgen kommt zwar nicht
so regelmäßig was aber ist auf jeden
fall ganz neues musical geworden wie ich
finde mal der channel sogar das
allerbeste aber ich will gar nicht mehr
lange drum herum reden wir schauen sie
einfach mal direkt mal ran
folgt mir hier beim musical ich als
theresa luca und macht coole sachen high
heels luca ausgestellt ich möchte ganz
kurz fast sagen ich habe dieses video
gerade geschnitten und irgendwie habe
ich fast alle leute die da irgendwie was
eingereicht haben unter dem hashtag
einfach fertig gemacht
tut mir leid ich habe ja so ein bisschen
angst gerade das so rüberkommt es jetzt
denkt dass ich überhaupt nichts feier
was ihnen mit dem hashtag gepostet wurde
unter dem hashtag kettenreaktionen nur
für mich war es halt so ich habe diese
möglichkeit bekommen über musik die so
eine eigene challenge zu machen und das
einzige beziehungsweise vieles was ich
mir dann gerade angeschaut habt war
einfach nicht so wie ich mir das
vorgestellt hatte allerdings wurden dort
echt auch coole videos gepostet also ich
habe ja auch diesmal jetzt hier zwei
drei videos echt richtig gut empfunden
wo wirklich diese kettenreaktion gemacht
wurden die beispielsweise der typ gerade
mit den spielen oder der eine der das
von seiner treppe runter gemacht hat und
damit der wasserflasche die umgekippt
ist also da waren ja echt coole sachen
bei und auch wenn man beim musical die
einfach mal unter diesem hashtag
nachschaute sind wirklich auch coole
videos mit dabei also es soll jetzt hier
überhaupt nie so rüber kommen als wenn
ich alles hätten würde was ihr irgendwie
veröffentlicht dort nun als ich das hier
gerade geschnitten habe habe ich mir
selber so gedacht luca warum machst du
dir dann so fertig die posten sachen
unter dem hashtag so sei doch froh
tut mir leid falls ihr euch angegriffen
gefühlt haben habe ich gebetet zurück an
luca de macht jetzt noch das auto und ja
das war's die heute vom video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn ja dann schreibt doch
einfach mal einen kommentar schreibt 1
kommentar wenn es euch gefallen hat aber
die leicht diese woche noch ausgemacht
einfach weil ich bessere kommentare
haben möchte also schreibt mir mal eine
ehrliche meinung betont in die
kommentare dann kann ich nicht
verbessern wenn ihr das video bis
hierhin geguckt hat dann schreibt man
musikerinnen die kommentare weil ich
dadurch sehe dass hier noch brand sei
cool und so wir sehen uns morgen in dem
anderen video wieder haut rein macht's
gut genießer wochenende sagt eurer
familie mal dass er sie liebt hat weil
das sagt man eigentlich viel zu selten
und tschüss